скроні
суд від лушпиння година справа не у бундесвері
товар слухати і дівчата у всіх ризикових
годину стінах і нарізаних по садах
потрібні тільки добрі орю коти
30 твориш на animal вухо було одні з
пішаків ринку офіцер займається
політичну і а також
участь у місіях бундесверу за кордоном
наша давно вона повернулася і сніданку
я помітила що c самотик ніж я хочу
займатися з розуму нарізним а ні за
дані на еблище 2 носити років я б
вирішила завищувати, а на службі то
мусульмани тужити і когось рис надовго
робота а ваке валися далі покоління
дружину крики прийшло бундесвер топер
пустого беня ти найвищої посади
вона малуха хоче зарубайко кар'єру в
бундесвері вона не боїться шовна
виринути всім проблема через те, що вона
ринку подивитись акцепті двір не можу
сказати що манерного знав і ми не
здаєте батька за слово самих ніг він і
змогли виявити особливе професій та
довести
щоб вона брала її лівою підковою малює
не джейн укп послаблюючи командний дух
дівчата наша пт він йому жити в місто ася
з вершини ми навантаження
поразки кіра ніші трапляються сари
людині в ризикову службу вти алли
жінку бундесвері назвав тане на c1 залі
поважаєш чол присутні неджі ніг у буде їх
сферах річку цивільних так і біля скронь їх
у поривах а там вже й жінка часто point
шуму підходить давай але не завдань
мани інок же мислити і покарала гаджет
проблеми он і дають дуже багато не маску
армію кейко місяців тому вперше врахував і
жінка міністром оборони стала урсула фон
дер line ви нас правді і накладатися
на боготур і j весь кого справа для неї
нове завдання зате геть звідси ви знаєте
на харчування дружину твою політикою
у бундесвері у всього 10 сотки в
дружину c дізнатися шия нам потреба я
багата срубає і вона коли я буваю у
ризикових частин нахта помічаю що там і
готовність брата щеня на службу а
дівчата я як я там за зустрічаю захоплений
вони у судді і тому, що ван і ух волини
правильне рішення він має вигляд стоячи ось
особливо ціни на льоду жити і жити від
стільникового формі
катя milling теж 1-го разу на я потиснув
que vale а про свої рішення піт і дав
бундесверу
вона на віскозі службі вже 10 руки у мережі
рук його нас чатувала як змінити
армія мало вдома маппет прямий про
бульбашки міністром цієї koch поліп шито
розумом та служби для ризикових з дітьми ми
не подібне c і d і відкривати десяткою
казармах яга даються було б навіть добрий
для солдатів week їх не така ситуація я
наприклад у мене моя сім'я та батьки
можуть людину живуть нападали
ними людина тест тут проти потрібно
створе вата умова для молодих робін
подивися всередину push off to a б 2 жінці
у ж кілька рук слухати уганда сфері
за контрактом он і перука він вони 2 ти
потрапив я принизити службу юже ніг в армії
А в бачиш розум і null і старше
покоління з ним просто на і мало праворуч
адау силу на веденого людини ставити а
дупа реджи ним ми не здавалася ще
спаюю ж ніг то він зміни вся став
що солдати стали крадіжок типу води
тис а1 і зубним пастам зинка скронь fpv
нині он і столи на вигляд земну частину
іншу німецьку армію спати біля своїх
калію почала служити і 2002-го руку краще
сцені вже рик служила еньші дівчата нині
ці на мою вже телком звучала я на
ситуація tanks на мальті тко у випадково
ситуація у тиммі те, що жінку бундесвері
завищуються розум n6